This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In recent weeks, people around the world have watched with anxiety as tensions between the Israelis and the Palestinians exploded once again into violence. Top story for you this morning. Israeli forces and Palestinian militants in Gaza have exchanged their heaviest bombardments in years. Angry posts about hurt and injustice fill social media feeds. News reports feature the voices of traumatized people. You see all the kids around me? They're just kids!
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。最近几周，世界各地的人们怀着焦虑的心情，目睹了以色列人和巴勒斯坦人之间的紧张局势再次演变成暴力冲突。这是今天早上的头条新闻。以色列军队和加沙的巴勒斯坦武装分子进行了多年来最猛烈的交火。社交媒体上充斥着关于伤害和不公的愤怒言论。新闻报道中充满了受创伤者的声音。你们看到我周围的孩子了吗？他们只是孩子！
Why would you just set a vessel to them and kill them? I'm Israeli and my son David was killed by a Palestinian sniper. Supporters of Israelis and supporters of Palestinians both have the same demand. Just look at what we are going through. If you opened your eyes, you would empathize with us. People are dying every day because of Israeli occupation. This was not like peaceful protests. It was just violence against Jews.
你为什么要向他们发射炮弹并杀死他们？我是以色列人，我的儿子大卫被一名巴勒斯坦狙击手杀害了。以色列人的支持者和巴勒斯坦人的支持者都有同样的要求。看看我们正在经历的一切吧。如果你睁开眼睛，你就会对我们感同身受。因为以色列的占领，人们每天都在死去。这不像和平抗议。这纯粹是对犹太人的暴力。
Why do we deserve this? It's not fear. It's not fear. The plea for empathy stems from a basic psychological desire. If we can just make others understand what happened to us, we think, they would care. And if they cared, they would do something to help. Our need for empathy is often not matched by our own capacity for empathy. Usually, we are too consumed with our own traumas, our own need for empathy, to direct our attention outward.
我们为什么应得这一切？这不是恐惧。这不是恐惧。对同理心的呼吁源于一种基本的心理渴望。我们认为，如果我们能让别人理解我们身上发生了什么，他们就会关心。如果他们关心，他们就会采取行动提供帮助。我们对同理心的需求往往与我们自身提供同理心的能力不匹配。通常，我们太沉浸于自己的创伤和对自己被同理的需求中，以至于无法将注意力转向外部。
This week on Hidden Brain, I want to share with you two stories from the archive that explore what happens when our prayers for empathy are actually answered. They point to the great power and the great risks that arise when you put yourself in someone else's shoes. I think that the two big elements that are lacking on both sides is one massive lack of hope and to this unbelievable lack of empathy. What was most helpful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. So my name is Avnere Gvaryahu, I'm 31 actually today. Growing up Avnere Gvaryahu was a model Israeli patriot. I grew up in religious family, what we call religious nationalist family, and I went to religious high school, what we call in Hebrew or Yashiva. I joined the army when I was 19 after doing a year of community service, and I served for three years as a paratrooper and a special ops unit.
本周在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我想与大家分享档案中的两个故事，探讨当我们的同理心祈求得到回应时会发生什么。它们指出了当你设身处地为他人着想时所产生的巨大力量和巨大风险。我认为双方都缺乏的两个重要因素是：一是极度缺乏希望，二是令人难以置信地缺乏同理心。对我来说，最痛苦、最无助的是没有人支持我。我叫阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡，今天我31岁了。阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡在成长过程中是一位模范的以色列爱国者。我在一个宗教家庭长大，也就是我们所说的宗教民族主义家庭，我上的是宗教高中，也就是希伯来语中所说的“叶史瓦”。我在做了一年社区服务后，于19岁参军，并在伞兵和特种作战部队服役了三年。
Being a soldier came naturally to Avner. In my society, in my community, and in my family as well, this was something that was discussed often. I'm named after a soldier who was killed in 1973 in the young Keeper War. My dad himself was a paratrooper. My older brother was a combat soldier. The people around me, my mentors, my teachers, my counselors, and my youth movement were all, of course, in the military. So I was really waiting for my chance to go and protect my country and serve.
成为一名士兵对阿夫纳来说是自然而然的事。在我的社会、我的社区以及我的家庭中，这都是经常讨论的话题。我的名字是以一位在1973年赎罪日战争中牺牲的士兵的名字命名的。我父亲本人就是一名伞兵。我哥哥是一名战斗士兵。我周围的人，我的导师、老师、辅导员和青年运动成员，当然都在军队里。所以我真的在等待机会去保护我的国家并服役。
That was sort of something that I always knew I would do, and I wanted to be the best I could be at that. But early in his military service, Avnarr started to see things that challenged his worldview. He was often asked to pull a maneuver known as a straw widow. This involved entering a Palestinian home to use the windows on the upper floors to cover other Israeli soldiers carrying out operations on the street. So I found myself numerous cases throughout my service, invading people's homes in the middle of the night, most of the time, after we knew that
这似乎是我一直知道自己会做的事情，而且我想在这方面做到最好。但在服役初期，阿夫纳开始看到一些挑战他世界观的事情。他经常被要求执行一种被称为“稻草寡妇”的战术。这涉及进入巴勒斯坦人的家中，利用楼上的窗户为在街上执行任务的其他以色列士兵提供掩护。因此，在服役期间，我多次发现自己不得不在深夜闯入人们的家中，大多数时候，在我们知道……
the people inside these homes were innocent. Because you do not want to enter someone's house if you know that he's involved in some terrorist organization. So what we actually did is you find a house on a map, you choose the house because it's situated in the right place, because it's elevated enough, because it has the the right size windows and you enter this house in the middle of the night. Now this house from that moment on belongs to the soldiers, right, to the family, wants to use the bathroom or the kitchen. In many cases they need permission from the soldiers.
这些房子里的人是无辜的情况下。因为如果你知道某人参与了恐怖组织，你是不想进入他家的。所以我们实际上做的是在地图上找一栋房子，选择它是因为它位置合适，因为它足够高，因为它有合适大小的窗户，然后我们在深夜进入这所房子。从那一刻起，这所房子就属于士兵了，对吧？如果家人想用浴室或厨房，在很多情况下，他们需要得到士兵的许可。
Of course the family can't leave their house. And this dynamic between soldiers and Palestinians was something that I was part of for many, many nights. And I think that that's where I really learned, for the first time, first of all, a little bit about the Palestinians, because I was never in a Palestinian home before I started my service. I had no real contacts with Palestinians before I started my service. I had no real contacts with Palestinians before I started my service. But also I learned about the power dynamic that I was part of. Just the fact that I was born sort of in the right side of the green line.
当然，这家人不能离开他们的房子。士兵和巴勒斯坦人之间的这种动态是我许多个夜晚亲身经历的一部分。我认为，正是在那里，我第一次真正了解了一些关于巴勒斯坦人的情况，因为在服役之前，我从未进入过巴勒斯坦人的家中。在服役之前，我与巴勒斯坦人没有任何真正的接触。在服役之前，我与巴勒斯坦人没有任何真正的接触。但我也了解了我所参与的权力动态。仅仅因为我出生在绿线的正确一侧。
Just the fact that I was born to an Israeli Jewish family gave me the power to walk in with a helmet with a gun with my, and I was in control of an entire family. One night in particular, stands out in his memory. We were supposed to take over our house, and we were walking through the open space around the house. We made maybe too much noise or maybe we stepped on a branch and we started hearing screaming from inside a Palestinian home. So me and the officer who were leading our soldiers went up to the window where we hear the screams,
仅仅因为我出生在一个以色列犹太家庭，我就有权戴着头盔、拿着枪走进去，并且控制了整个家庭。有一个夜晚，我记忆犹新。我们本应接管一所房子，我们正走在房子周围的空地上。我们可能制造了太大的噪音，或者可能踩到了树枝，我们开始听到巴勒斯坦人家里传来的尖叫声。于是，我和带领士兵的军官走到我们听到尖叫声的窗户前，
because we could be detected. And that's not something we want. And we break the glass of this house and we peer in with our rifles. We had flashlights on the barrels. And we see on the floor of this house an older lady, an elderly lady helpless. And she was on the floor, I don't know what exactly happened, but maybe she heard us and she was petrified and she just fell off her bed. I remember looking to the other side of the room
因为我们可能会被发现。这不是我们想要的。我们打破了这所房子的玻璃，用步枪向内窥视。我们的枪管上装有手电筒。我们看到这所房子的地板上有一位年长的女士，一位无助的老妇人。她躺在地板上，我不知道具体发生了什么，但也许她听到了我们的声音，她被吓坏了，直接从床上掉了下来。我记得看向房间的另一边，
and I could see at the end of the corridor, some people or voices, and it was her family who were petrified to come and help her. And I remember standing there and telling myself, this is not what I thought I would be doing. This is definitely not promoting the security of my country or the security of my family, and I started thinking, what about the family of this old lady? What do they think about me now?
我可以看到走廊尽头有一些人或声音，那是她的家人，他们被吓得不敢过来帮助她。我记得站在那里对自己说，这不是我以为我会做的事情。这绝对不是在促进我国的安全或我家人的安全，我开始想，这位老妇人的家人呢？他们现在怎么看我？
Moments like this are what prompted Auvner to start working with an organization called Breaking the Silence, a group of military veterans who want to talk openly about what they've learned. From Auvner's perspective, there is nothing unpatriotic about Israeli veterans telling their stories, talking about moments they struggle with or Palestinian families they got to know.
像这样的时刻促使阿夫纳开始与一个名为“打破沉默”的组织合作，这是一个由退伍军人组成的团体，他们希望公开谈论他们所学到的东西。从阿夫纳的角度来看，以色列退伍军人讲述他们的故事，谈论他们挣扎的时刻或他们所认识的巴勒斯坦家庭，这并没有什么不爱国的。
But others see it differently. Some see it as treason. In one recent video, a group targeting Avnare shows a Palestinian attacking in Israel with a knife. The video then accuses four human rights activists, including Avnare, of protecting the terrorist.
但其他人有不同的看法。有些人认为这是叛国。在最近的一段视频中，一个针对阿夫纳的团体展示了一名巴勒斯坦人用刀袭击以色列人的画面。视频随后指责包括阿夫纳在内的四名人权活动人士保护恐怖分子。
They called all four of us foreign agents, or what they called it, were stulim, which basically means implanted, meaning my opinions, my thoughts, and the actions of myself and my friends are not things we actually think on our own, but we're actually working for, um, uh, foreign government, um, to us it sounded that if they're blaming us for being spies. As I was listening to Avnare, I couldn't stop thinking about a study I read many years ago. Psychologist Lee Ross ran an experiment at Stanford University.
他们称我们四个人为外国代理人，或者他们所说的“stulim”，这基本上意味着“植入者”，意思是我的观点、我的想法以及我和朋友们的行动并不是我们自己真正想出来的，而是我们在为外国政府工作。对我们来说，这听起来就像他们指责我们是间谍。当我在听阿夫纳讲述时，我不禁想起了我多年前读过的一项研究。心理学家李·罗斯在斯坦福大学进行了一项实验。
He brought in students from a pro-Israeli group and a pro-Arab group and had them watch television news clips about the Arab-Israeli conflict. He found the pro-Israeli students saw lots of anti-Israel references in the news clips, whereas the pro-Arab students saw lots of anti-Arab references while looking at the very same new scripts. When Arabs in Israel think about their conflict, each group desperately wants observers to know that they have been wronged. To acknowledge the pain on the other side is to somehow limit this claim. That's why two groups can look at the same reality and see completely different things.
他找来了亲以色列团体和亲阿拉伯团体的学生，让他们观看关于阿以冲突的电视新闻片段。他发现，亲以色列的学生在新闻片段中看到了许多反以色列的参考内容，而亲阿拉伯的学生在观看完全相同的新闻片段时，却看到了许多反阿拉伯的参考内容。当以色列的阿拉伯人和犹太人思考他们的冲突时，每一方都迫切希望观察者知道他们受到了冤屈。承认对方的痛苦在某种程度上会限制这种主张。这就是为什么两个群体可以看着同一个现实，却看到完全不同的东西。
I told Avner, his story reminded me of the study. As you're telling me the story, I'm realizing that one of the psychological implications of your work is that really when you try and empathize with what the other side is going through, there is something about that action that drives your friends and comrades really angry. The idea that one of you would empathize with the other side feels like betrayal. Yeah, I think that you're touching a point which is true and I think is extremely difficult. Silence is not an Israeli disease, it's not an Israeli epidemic. There is no society, there is no community that does not live with this disease of silence.
我告诉阿夫纳，他的故事让我想起了这项研究。当你给我讲这个故事时，我意识到你工作的心理暗示之一是，当你试图对另一方所经历的事情产生同理心时，这种行为会让你的朋友和战友感到非常愤怒。你们中的一个人会对另一方产生同理心的想法感觉像是背叛。是的，我认为你触及了一个事实，我认为这极其困难。沉默不是一种以色列疾病，它不是一种以色列流行病。没有哪个社会、没有哪个社区不生活在这种沉默的疾病中。
A big part of what breaking the silence and saying is, you know, the fact that we are talking about our actions, of course it doesn't mean there's no responsibility in the Palestinian side. But you know, when I do think about what can create change and who has the power for change, I can't ignore the fact that in this specific point, we are the ones with the power. When we come back, a Palestinian professor tries to get his students to empathize with Israelis. If you learn about the suffering of the other, what that help and your attitude for reconciliation. Stay with us. The psychologist Michael Wall and Nyla Branscom wants us Jewish volunteers to think about the suffering of Palestinians.
“打破沉默”组织所说的大部分内容是，你知道，我们谈论我们的行为，当然这并不意味着巴勒斯坦方面没有责任。但是，你知道，当我思考什么能创造改变以及谁有权改变时，我无法忽视这样一个事实：在这一点上，我们是拥有权力的一方。当我们回来时，一位巴勒斯坦教授试图让他的学生对以色列人产生同理心。如果你了解对方的苦难，这会有助于你对和解的态度吗？请留下来。心理学家迈克尔·沃尔和奈拉·布兰斯科姆希望犹太志愿者思考巴勒斯坦人的苦难。
The psychologists reminded some of the volunteers about the Holocaust. Compared to others, Jews reminded of their own group suffering showed less compassion toward Palestinian suffering. The same thing happens with other groups. Americans, reminded of traumas, even distant traumas like the Pearl Harbor attack, show less empathy for victims of torture carried out by American service members. Trauma makes us turn inward. It creates justifications for the harm we cause other groups.
心理学家提醒一些志愿者关于大屠杀的事情。与其他被提醒自身群体苦难的人相比，被提醒大屠杀的犹太人对巴勒斯坦人的苦难表现出更少的同情。同样的事情也发生在其他群体身上。美国人在被提醒创伤时，即使是像珍珠港事件这样遥远的创伤，对美国军人实施酷刑的受害者表现出的同理心也较少。创伤使我们转向内心。它为我们对其他群体造成的伤害创造了正当理由。
It makes it harder to feel empathy for our enemies. In 1948, hundreds of thousands of Palestinians lost their homes during the creation of the state of Israel. Palestinians have a word to describe this trauma, they call it the Nakba, the catastrophe. Just as traumatized Israelis don't want to think about the Nakba, traumatized Palestinians don't want to think about the Nakba, traumatized Palestinians, don't want to think about the Holocaust. Muhammad Dijani used to be one of those Palestinians who struggled to empathize with Israelis. He considered himself a nationalist.
这使我们更难对敌人产生同理心。1948年，成千上万的巴勒斯坦人在以色列建国期间失去了家园。巴勒斯坦人用一个词来描述这种创伤，他们称之为“Nakba”，即灾难。正如受过创伤的以色列人不想去想“Nakba”一样，受过创伤的巴勒斯坦人也不想去想大屠杀。穆罕默德·迪贾尼曾经是那些难以对以色列人产生同理心的巴勒斯坦人之一。他认为自己是一名民族主义者。
In fact, as a result of his political work for Palestinian statehood, Muhammad says he was forced into exile from his native Jerusalem. He was allowed to return in 1993 because his father was very sick. And then, just like Avner, something happened to Muhammad that shook his beliefs about his enemy. In the beginning it was very difficult for me to adjust, but my father, what cancer, started taking me to an incarem hospital where he used to have chemotherapy. And it made me observe my enemy, the Israelis, the doctors, the nurses, the staff. I noticed that their attitude to my father was not an attitude of an enemy to his enemy, but rather a
事实上，由于他为巴勒斯坦建国所做的政治工作，穆罕默德说他被迫流亡离开了他土生土长的耶路撒冷。1993年，因为父亲病重，他获准返回。然后，就像阿夫纳一样，穆罕默德身上发生了一件事，动摇了他对敌人的看法。起初，我很难适应，但我父亲患了癌症，开始带我去因卡雷姆医院接受化疗。这让我观察到了我的敌人——以色列人、医生、护士、工作人员。我注意到他们对待我父亲的态度不是敌人对敌人的态度，而更像是……
doctor to his patient. Another time, Muhammad's mother suffered a heart attack. He was in a car with her, his brother was driving. We were coming to the Mongolian airport exit and my brother decided to take that exit. Muhammad told his brother he was being foolish. Israeli soldiers would stop them, harass them. Muhammad's brother said they had no choice. He pulled up at a security gate.
医生对病人的态度。还有一次，穆罕默德的母亲心脏病发作。他和她坐在车里，他哥哥在开车。我们正要到达蒙古机场出口，我哥哥决定走那个出口。穆罕默德告诉他哥哥他太傻了。以色列士兵会拦住他们，骚扰他们。穆罕默德的哥哥说他们别无选择。他把车开到了安全门前。
When we came to the gates of the airport, the enemy brother told them that we have a sick woman with us and they saw her. They vacated one of the gates there and immediately called for ambulance there when the doctors came. They found out that they cannot move her so they tried to restate her there so it became like an operation room. These experiences changed Muhammad. He says he stopped thinking of the conflict in terms of Palestinians versus Israelis and started thinking in terms of the Palestinians and Israelis who were
当我们来到机场大门时，敌人的兄弟告诉他们，我们带了一位生病的妇女，他们看到了她。他们腾出了其中一个大门，并立即在那里呼叫了救护车。当医生赶到时，他们发现无法移动她，所以他们试图在那里对她进行复苏，那里变成了一个手术室。这些经历改变了穆罕默德。他说他不再从巴勒斯坦人对阵以色列人的角度来思考冲突，而是开始从……
four peace and the Palestinians and Israelis who were against peace. And for the very first time he says he tried to see the Palestinian Israeli conflict from the Israeli point of view. He began teaching political science at Al-Quds University in Jerusalem, and he brought his new understanding with him. But his students couldn't relate. They hadn't had encounters with kind Israeli soldiers and carrying Jewish doctors. In order to come to the university,
支持和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人，以及反对和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人来思考。他说，这是他第一次尝试从以色列人的角度来看待巴以冲突。他开始在耶路撒冷的圣城大学教授政治学，并带来了他的新理解。但他的学生们无法产生共鸣。他们没有遇到过善良的以色列士兵和富有同情心的犹太医生。为了来到大学，
they used to go through many checkpoints, so they would leave something like three in the morning to get to the university at nine. Muhammad tried to get his students to see beyond the soldiers their method checkpoints every day. The university set up an Israeli studies program and an American studies program and he started to broach a topic most Palestinians had never encountered at school, the Holocaust. But Muhammad students consumed as they were with their own trauma, could not or would not listen. One of his students was a young woman named Hanan.
他们必须经过许多检查站，所以他们通常在凌晨三点左右出发，才能在九点到达大学。穆罕默德试图让他的学生看到那些每天在检查站拦截他们的士兵之外的东西。大学设立了以色列研究项目和美国研究项目，他开始谈论大多数巴勒斯坦人在学校从未接触过的话题——大屠杀。但穆罕默德的学生们沉浸在自己的创伤中，不能或不愿倾听。他的一名学生是一位名叫哈南的年轻女子。
And she was in Israeli presence for nine years. So to her, she looked at what happened with Jews, in Auschwitz, in Krakow, in different, back and now, in different concentration camps, as if transmitting that to her own experience being a prisoner in Israeli jails and being discriminated against as a woman. Muhammad told Hananshi had constructed a prison inside her own mind, a prison that kept her from seeing the world from the point of view of her enemy. When nothing worked with the students, Muhammad decided he would take Hanan and a couple dozen other students on a field trip to Europe.
她在以色列监狱里待了九年。所以对她来说，她看待犹太人在奥斯威辛、克拉科夫以及不同集中营里发生的事情，就好像将其投射到她自己作为以色列监狱囚犯并因女性身份而受到歧视的经历上一样。穆罕默德告诉哈南，她在自己的脑海中建造了一座监狱，这座监狱使她无法从敌人的角度看世界。当对学生们采取任何方法都不奏效时，穆罕默德决定带哈南和其他几十名学生去欧洲进行实地考察。
They would visit Nazi concentration camps and learn, first hand, about the trauma at the heart of the Israeli Jewish experience. It was a scientific project to study about empathy, about if you learn about the suffering of the other, would that help more in your attitude for reconciliation? We decided to take these 30 Palestinian students' torches and Krakow in Poland. Almost immediately, there was trouble. So I received an email from the president of the university. He said that I heard rumors that you are taking students to
他们将参观纳粹集中营，亲身了解以色列犹太人经历核心的创伤。这是一个关于同理心的科学项目，研究如果你了解对方的苦难，这是否会有助于你对和解的态度？我们决定带这30名巴勒斯坦学生去波兰的克拉科夫。几乎立刻，麻烦就来了。我收到了大学校长的一封电子邮件。他说，我听说有传言说你要带学生去……
Joshua's. And I would like you to make it very clear to them that the university has nothing to do with this trip. Another student came to me and said, you should cancel this trip and that if you would go once you come back, you might be facing a very big threat. Muhammad did not waver. He was an educator and like Avner, he believed he was being a patriot. Empathy, he had come to believe, was the only way to understanding and to peace.
奥斯威辛。我希望你向他们明确表示，大学与这次旅行无关。另一名学生来找我说，你应该取消这次旅行，如果你去了，回来后可能会面临巨大的威胁。穆罕默德没有动摇。他是一名教育家，像阿夫纳一样，他相信自己是一位爱国者。他开始相信，同理心是通往理解与和平的唯一途径。
When they got to Auschwitz, Muhammad and Hanan stopped at the entrance, there was like a blackout saying, Arbite-Macht-Frey, the so-work sets you free. So she was very surprised with that slogan on the at the gate of the Auschwitz camp and asked me about it and I said, why don't you lock it up? Hanan learned the meaning of the cynical phrase. The Jewish prisoners who entered this camp were not set free by work. They were worked to death or killed. There was this big room which had toilets and we were told that every morning more than 2000 people gathered
当他们到达奥斯威辛时，穆罕默德和哈南停在入口处，那里有一个牌子写着“Arbeit macht frei”，即“劳动带来自由”。所以她对集中营门口的这个口号感到非常惊讶，并问我关于它的事，我说，你为什么不读读看？哈南了解了这个讽刺短语的含义。进入这个集中营的犹太囚犯并没有因为劳动而获得自由。他们被劳役致死或被杀害。有一个大房间里有厕所，我们被告知每天早上有超过2000人聚集……
in front of the room and then they make them go through there to use it and they are given 10 seconds to use it and then they have to leave. And so it was such a humiliation for the individual. They were things they never heard of in terms of how human beings were humiliated and broken. As they walked through the camp, Muhammad noticed that Hanan and the other students were no longer seeing the Holocaust through the lens of their own suffering. They were actually empathizing with Jews, their enemies. It was very emotional to them, one of the, and some of the, some of the girls even cried. One of the students was telling me, I thought that Hitler gathered Jews in these concentration camps to send them to Palestine,
在房间前，然后他们让他们进去使用，只给他们10秒钟时间，然后他们必须离开。这对个人来说是一种极大的羞辱。他们听到了从未听说过的事情，关于人类是如何被羞辱和摧毁的。当他们走过集中营时，穆罕默德注意到哈南和其他学生不再通过自己受苦的视角来看待大屠杀。他们实际上是在同情犹太人，他们的敌人。这对他们来说非常感人，其中一些女孩甚至哭了。其中一名学生告诉我，我以为希特勒把犹太人聚集在这些集中营里是为了把他们送到巴勒斯坦，
to have them shipped to Palestine. So to them, they had total misconception about what is the Holocaust, what is the concentration camp, what did it mean, how life was there, And so it was an open-air for them. But back at home, Muhammad's colleagues at the university did not see the trip as an invaluable educational experience. The last day in Auschwitz, my secretary, did not see the trip as an invaluable educational experience. The last day in Auschwitz, my secretary wrote to me an email saying that students have come in the Rennes-Aktor office and they were making demonstrations against
把他们运到巴勒斯坦。所以对他们来说，他们对什么是大屠杀、什么是集中营、生活在那里意味着什么有完全错误的认识，所以这对他们来说是一个大开眼界的经历。但在家里，穆罕默德在大学的同事们并不认为这次旅行是一次宝贵的教育经历。在奥斯威辛的最后一天，我的秘书写了一封电子邮件给我，说学生们已经进入了校长办公室，他们正在针对……
your own campus and that they came and left you a letter of threatening your life that you should not come back to the university and that if you come back they are going to kill you. And the letter is with me and she said that they were extremely, there is a lot of enmity and an uproar on campus regarding the trip. So, anyway, that prepared me that the reception will not be easy going back to the university. And once I went there, I noticed that there was a lot of enmity people were looking at me as if I have a betrayer, betrayed them. At the same time, nine student organizations issued a statement on campus saying that this is normalization and normalization equals treason. Muhammad was forced to resign from his job. One night, someone set fire to his car. He knew his life was in danger.
你的校园进行示威，他们来并留下了一封威胁你生命的信，说你不应该回到大学，如果你回来，他们就会杀了你。信在我这里，她说他们非常愤怒，校园里对这次旅行有很多敌意和骚乱。总之，这让我做好了回到大学后不会轻松的准备。当我回到那里时，我注意到有很多敌意，人们看着我，好像我是一个背叛了他们的叛徒。与此同时，九个学生组织在校园发表声明，称这是“正常化”，而“正常化”等于“叛国”。穆罕默德被迫辞职。一天晚上，有人放火烧了他的车。他知道自己的生命处于危险之中。
He packed his bags and left Jerusalem again. This time, exiled by his fellow Palestinians. I asked him how it felt to be called a traitor. What was most hurtful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. ما كان مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصدر مصد مصدر مصدر مصدر مصد for the Palestinian cause, and suddenly I met a traitor for that cause, so that also was painful. When I talked to Muhammad, he was living in Washington, just like Avner, who is also in the United States, Muhammad hopes to go home someday. When we come back, an artist tries to reconcile the traumas of the Nakpa and the Holocaust. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
他收拾行李再次离开了耶路撒冷。这一次，是被他的巴勒斯坦同胞流放的。我问他被称作叛徒是什么感觉。对我来说，最伤人、最痛苦的是没有人支持我。我曾是巴勒斯坦事业的坚定支持者，突然间我成了该事业的叛徒，这也很痛苦。当我与穆罕默德交谈时，他住在华盛顿，就像同样在美国的阿夫纳一样，穆罕默德希望有一天能回家。当我们回来时，一位艺术家试图调和“Nakba”和大屠杀的创伤。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Avanar Gwariahu and Mahamad Dajani did something that few of us are capable of doing. They decided to take the radical step of empathizing with their enemies. Almost instantly, this produced a backlash. Many of Avnars' fellow Israelis branded him a traitor. Many of Muhammad's fellow Palestinians said he had betrayed them. Both men felt they were doing their patriotic duty but both suffered ostracism as a result of their actions. Their experience sadly is anything but surprising. Throughout human history, peacemakers have often been greeted with suspicion, even outright hostility. Mending fences calls on us to give up grievances, set aside traumas.
阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡和穆罕默德·迪贾尼做了我们大多数人无法做到的事情。他们决定采取激进的步骤，去同情他们的敌人。几乎立刻，这引发了强烈的反弹。许多阿夫纳的以色列同胞称他为叛徒。许多穆罕默德的巴勒斯坦同胞说他背叛了他们。两人都觉得自己在履行爱国职责，但都因自己的行为而遭受了排斥。他们的经历令人悲哀地一点也不令人惊讶。纵观人类历史，和平缔造者往往受到怀疑，甚至受到彻底的敌意。修补裂痕要求我们放弃不满，放下创伤。
This is psychologically painful. It requires an enormous amount of emotional work. Anger and hostility by contrast come naturally. Standing shoulder to shoulder with your tribe does not involve psychological heavy lifting. As I was learning the stories of Avner Guariaku and Muhammad Dajani, I went to see a powerful new play called Wrestling Jerusalem. Like Avner and Muhammad's real-life stories, the play is about the intertwined traumas of the Nakba and the Holocaust, and the effects those traumas have on the ability of Israelis
这在心理上是痛苦的。它需要大量的心理工作。相比之下，愤怒和敌意是自然而然的。与你的部落肩并肩站在一起并不涉及心理上的重负。在学习阿夫纳·格瓦里亚胡和穆罕默德·迪贾尼的故事时，我去看了一部名为《摔跤耶路撒冷》的震撼人心的新剧。就像阿夫纳和穆罕默德的真实故事一样，这部剧讲述了“Nakba”和大屠杀交织在一起的创伤，以及这些创伤对以色列人……
and Palestinians to empathize with one another. Playwright and performer Aaron Davidman describes his travels in Israel and the occupied territories. You'll hear him speak as himself and in the voices of Palestinians and an Israeli man named Nadav. I'm looking for the number 18 bus in East Jerusalem, somewhere up the street from Damascus Gate, the Arab entrance to the old city. It's only a few blocks from the Jewish part of Jerusalem, but it feels like another world, the smell of the food vendors, language in the air, gestures of the people in the street,
和巴勒斯坦人相互同情能力的影响。剧作家兼表演者亚伦·戴维曼描述了他在以色列和被占领土的旅行。你将听到他以自己的身份，以及巴勒斯坦人和一位名叫纳达夫的以色列男子的声音说话。我在东耶路撒冷寻找18路公交车，在大马士革门（通往老城的阿拉伯入口）上方街道的某个地方。它距离耶路撒冷的犹太区只有几个街区，但感觉像是另一个世界，食品摊贩的气味、空气中的语言、街上人们的手势，
all so different. I can't find the bus stop and have a nervous feeling of being on the other side. I've been to Israel many times. I've never been to Ramallah. When I finally find the small bus, I pay six shekels and I get on. I sit in the back. I'm sure I'm the only Jewish person on the bus, but I feel invisible. No one seems to pay any attention to me. The atmosphere is quiet, tired. As soon as we get on the highway, the bus is stopped by the Israeli police. Tadzut, vaksha! I clutch my passport.
都如此不同。我找不到公交车站，有一种身处另一边的紧张感。我去过以色列很多次。我从未去过拉马拉。当我终于找到那辆小巴时，我付了六谢克尔并上了车。我坐在后面。我敢肯定我是车上唯一的犹太人，但我感觉自己是隐形的。似乎没有人注意我。气氛安静而疲惫。我们一上高速公路，公交车就被以色列警察拦住了。“Tadzut, vaksha!”（请出示证件！）我紧紧抓住我的护照。
I don't want to pass it forward. I just sit there. The officer doesn't see me. Now my invisibility feels conspicuous. There's a blank stare in the eyes of the middle-aged Palestinian men as they pass their IDs forward. Do you speak English? A woman turns to me. Did they ask to see your ID? No.
我不想把它传过去。我就坐在那里。警察没看见我。现在我的隐形感变得引人注目了。当那些中年巴勒斯坦男人把身份证传过去时，他们的眼神中有一种茫然。你会说英语吗？一个女人转向我。他们要求看你的身份证了吗？没有。
You see how they humiliate us. Ten minutes later, we approach the Kalandia checkpoint. There's a long line of cars and people on foot waiting to cross through. Manned by the Israeli Army, Kalandia is one of the few places to cross from Israel into the West Bank and from the West Bank into Israel. Hundreds of kilometers of electric fences, trenches, barbed wire, and eight-meter high concrete walls run north and south of this crossing, creating a de facto border. But Selam, the Israeli human rights organization, calls this structure the separation barrier. The Israelis call it the security fence, the Palestinians call it the apartheid wall. Whatever you want to call it, it's massive and intimidating and haunting.
你看到他们是如何羞辱我们的吗？十分钟后，我们接近卡兰迪亚检查站。有一长排汽车和行人等着通过。卡兰迪亚由以色列军队把守，是少数几个从以色列进入西岸以及从西岸进入以色列的通道之一。数百公里的电网、战壕、铁丝网和八米高的混凝土墙沿着这个过境点的南北延伸，形成了一个事实上的边界。以色列人权组织“B'Tselem”称这种结构为“隔离墙”。以色列人称之为“安全围栏”，巴勒斯坦人称之为“种族隔离墙”。无论你想怎么称呼它，它都是巨大的、令人生畏的，且令人难以忘怀。
The Kalandia crossing is a rocky, no-man's land, with two giant ominous watchtowers surrounded by fences laced with barbed wire. Concentration camps. All I can think of is concentration camps. Concentration camps. All I can think of is concentration camps. Concentration camps. A lifetime of holocaust imagery comes lurching forward from the back of my mind. No! Don't think of concentration camps.
卡兰迪亚过境点是一片岩石嶙峋的无人区，有两个巨大的、不祥的瞭望塔，周围环绕着缠绕着铁丝网的围栏。集中营。我能想到的只有集中营。集中营。我能想到的只有集中营。集中营。一生的关于大屠杀的意象从我的脑海深处涌现出来。不！不要去想集中营。
There's no moral equivalency here. It's not the same. It's not the same guard towers, guard dogs, barbed wire, soldiers, machine guns, refugees, suitcases. Now the Jews are the guards and I'm on the train going into the camps and I I I I I I I remember
这里没有道德上的等同性。这不是一回事。这不是一回事，同样的岗楼、警犬、铁丝网、士兵、机枪、难民、手提箱。现在犹太人是守卫，而我正坐在开往集中营的火车上，我……我……我记得……
Nadav and Aron, the craziest thing, when I got here, I did not yet know my gilly was on this bus. I did not know I heard on the radio of the Piguah, the bombing, and I come right here, it's my neighborhood. In Haifa we don't expect such things. And I stood here in the street, and I could smell burn flesh in the air, and at that moment I had this strange feeling. I thought this must be the smell, the people smelled coming off the trains in Auschwitz, the smell of the crematoriums.
纳达夫和亚伦，最疯狂的事情是，当我来到这里时，我还不知道我的吉利就在这辆车上。我不知道，我在广播里听到了“Piguah”（恐怖袭击），爆炸，我来到这里，这是我的社区。在海法，我们没预料到会发生这种事。我站在街上，能闻到空气中烧焦的肉味，那一刻我有一种奇怪的感觉。我想这一定是人们在奥斯威辛下火车时闻到的味道，火葬场的味道。
My parents were the only survivors of the family to make it out alive. Every other member of the family was killed. Every single one, uncles, aunts, everyone completely destroyed and here, 60 years later, my gilly, burn alive in such brutal murder. He was 13 years old. He was in the peace camp for Palestinian and Israeli children just two weeks before. Look, I don't hate the Arabs, but build the wall. Absolutely build the wall. Let them live over there and we live over here. I'm finished. over there and we leave over here, I'm finished! And I'm staring at this wall, of the window of the bus, at the Kalandia checkpoint,
我的父母是家里唯一幸存下来的人。家里的其他成员都被杀了。每一个，叔叔、阿姨，所有人完全被摧毁，而在这里，60年后，我的吉利，在如此残酷的谋杀中被活活烧死。他才13岁。就在两周前，他还在巴勒斯坦和以色列儿童的和平营里。听着，我不恨阿拉伯人，但建墙吧。绝对要建墙。让他们住在那边，我们住在这边。我受够了。住在那边，我们住在这边，我受够了！我盯着这堵墙，透过公交车的窗户，在卡兰迪亚检查站，
and six million ghosts chase me as we drive through, and I wonder if they will ever rest. Aaron Davidman, performing an excerpt from his play, Wrestling Jerusalem. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero for this episode is the psychologist Lee Ross. I cited one of Lee's studies in this episode. What I didn't say was that his studies were among
六百万个幽灵在我们穿过时追逐着我，我不知道他们是否会安息。亚伦·戴维曼，表演他的戏剧《摔跤耶路撒冷》的片段。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特姆·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本集的无名英雄是心理学家李·罗斯。我在本集中引用了李的一项研究。我没说的是，他的研究是……
the first to show me how psychological research can speak to our daily lives. The studies and experiments done in labs are not just the stuff of dry academic research. They speak to urgent concerns and life and death issues. Lee Roth spent a lifetime studying questions like the ones we explored in this episode. Sadly, he passed away just a few days ago. His protege, Docker Keltner, described him as a combination of Shakespeare and the Marks brothers. Thank you Lee. You are the very definition of an unsung hero. If you like this episode, please consider supporting our work. You can do so by going to support.hiddenbrain.org.
第一批向我展示心理学研究如何与我们的日常生活对话的研究。在实验室中完成的研究和实验不仅仅是枯燥的学术研究。它们关乎紧迫的关切和生死攸关的问题。李·罗斯一生都在研究像我们在本集中探讨的那样的问题。令人悲伤的是，他几天前去世了。他的门生多克·凯尔特纳形容他是莎士比亚和马克思兄弟的结合体。谢谢你，李。你是无名英雄的真正定义。如果你喜欢这一集，请考虑支持我们的工作。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来做到这一点。
Please also share this episode with two friends. If they are new to podcasts, show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也请与两位朋友分享这一集。如果他们是播客新手，请教他们如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。